all right this has been a long time
coming and I'm super excited and nervous
about this because I don't know how it's
going to go I've teased for a while that
we've been working on a children's book
on critical thinking as so many of you
know I've identified one of the many
problems we have in education in the
United States is we're not teaching
critical thinking to kids nearly early
enough
I've written with our team a book for
kids on critical thinking I have the
first proof
right in front of me and I'm holding it
up this one labeled not for resale
this book
is now available on Amazon
we did an email blast this morning
and the copies are flying off the
shelves it is unbelievable what's going
on
I don't pretend for a second that this
40 page book including illustrations and
dedication and everything that this 40
page book is going to solve the critical
thinking crisis we have but this is a
book that six seven eight-year-olds can
read with their parents uh 9 10 11 12
year olds can read by themselves it is
about starting to think critically when
someone says something how do we know
that it's true how do we know that we
know anything
I can't tell you I I've heard from
people saying David I'm buying 25 copies
I'm going to bring them to my local
libraries and give them uh give them
away I'm buying these as gifts for I
don't have kids but I'm buying them for
my my nephews and so on and so forth
it's available in Kindle and in
paperback the Kindle is pre-order it's
going to launch Tuesday pre-order it now
please help us with the pre-orders only
a couple hundred pre-orders
can put us at number one for the
category this is you know we're used to
hundreds of thousands and millions being
the numbers we talk about on YouTube and
podcast Etc a few hundred orders of this
book today will put us at the top of the
category and then all bets are off uh I
want to
um also mention that this copy I have
here is the first proof we're going to
call it like proof zero I am going to
give this proof away to someone who buys
the book I'll tell you how to take
advantage of that in the future
everybody who buys it will be eligible
so I'll be doing that I'll I'll give
this copy away I got two proofs one I'm
Gonna Save for my daughter who by the
way loves the book already she can't
read she just loved the pictures
probably is going to rip the book up
very very soon so I may need to get a
couple more proofs uh you go to
davidpackman.com book
that's it davidpackman.com book uh make
sure to leave a review
Kindle paperback I'm going to update you
on how this goes but it is a super
exciting new thing that we're doing and
it is only available
at davidpackman.com book we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this